- Hi everyone, I hope you're
having an amazing day,
it's Mark Wiens.
We just arrived in Kandy, Sri Lanka
which is in central
Sri Lanka on a plateau,
it's a lush beautiful city.
And today's for lunch,
Ruzaina has invited us to--
Her aunt owns a lodge
and so we're staying at the lodge.
But her grandma has come from her home
to cook for us a very special
home-cooked all beef meal.
The dishes that we're
gonna have are unique,
they're not typically
available at restaurants.
We're hopefully gonna see a little bit
of the cooking.
We're gonna eat some
incredibly delicious food
and just have a chance
to hang out with granny
and I'm gonna share all the food
with you in this video.
(upbeat music)
- The tongue.
- [Mark] The tongue?
- Yeah.
- That will remain.
- This is cooking the intestines.
We are heavy meat eaters.
- Awesome.
Heavy meat eaters.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- [Mark] I like the sound
of that, millet roti.
- Millet roti, yes.
- Millet roti.
- [Grandma] Yeah, of course. (laughs)
- We made it to Kandy,
we are in the kitchen now
with grandma and some
of Ruzaina's relatives.
And they are preparing
very special meal for us
that's gonna be all parts of the cow.
There's tongue, there's hoof,
there's intestines, there's--
- Beef!
- Beef, the meet.
- Yeah, meat.
- Beef meat.
All made into a variety
of different curries.
The entire tongue is curled
up in a single clay pot curry
which looks incredible.
Right now she's making some millet roti,
which is there's flour, there's
coconut, shredded coconut
in the recipe there's--
- [Grandma] roti Olive oil.
There's olive oil and then
what's unique about that roti
is that she rolls it out
and then folds it over
like four times so that it has layers
and then that goes on the hot plate
to really slow cook.
Break a piece.
- [Ruzaina] Look Mark, just break a piece
see how soft it is.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, it's
so soft, like crispy.
Fresh off the grill and
I can't wait to try it.
(Mark Wiens music)
Yeah, that's delicious.
It's a flat bread and yet at the same time
it's kind of fluffy, delicious.
(happy music)
- [Grandma] I need cardamon too.
I can't finish all that.
- [Mark] Okay.
(happy music)
The pot roast tongue was already
prepared when we arrived,
but she's getting ready
to make another tongue.
I saw the tongue that
was sitting in the sink.
There's another tongue uncooked,
she's getting ready to
prepare that right now.
(tap water dripping)
She is washing the tongue now
with some powdered tumeric
to really clean it off, really prepare it
before it's gonna get
cooked, the entire tongue.
That's like a foot long.
(tap water dripping)
(happy music)
- [Grandma] Cardamon, cinnamon,
and then curry leaves
and put some ginger, crushed ginger,
garlic.
(oil simmering)
- She added in the ingredients
to some simmering coconut oil
and immediately you could smell the aroma
coming out of the cloves,
the onions, the garlic.
Oh, it smells delicious immediately.
(grandma laughs lightly)
Okay.
(happy music)
(oil simmering)
- This is very special.
- *** yes, you know.
- Not yet until you add water.
Water and then chili powder.
- And then chili powder.
- And some pepper.
(happy music)
Until now we have to add salt.
- [Mark] Okay, that will cook for a while.
- Yes, for about--
- Then we can--
(chattering)
- Would that be coconut vinegar.
To the tongue dish, she just added a spoon
of coconut vinegar and you can immediately
smell the fumes coming out of that,
the steam, those sour vinegary fumes.
They're gonna be also making a rice dish.
So that's rice with some shredded coconut
and then some salt and some flour
and then it's gonna--
- Will I add more?
- The rice is already cooked?
- Yeah, rice is cooked.
- You're gonna form it into little--
- And we're gonna steam it.
- Steam it in a--
- In concoction lid.
- Concoction, that what it's
called, a concoction, yes.
(Mark and Ruzaina laughing)
I don't know what to call it.
Concoction is good.
- Yeah.
- Contraption.
- Contraption is better.
- You really like mash it up, blend it,
mesh it with your fingers to get the rice
completely blended with the coconut.
A little bit of flour to hold it together
and then make it into funnel
cylinder cakes of rice.
In their community, this
community this is a common dish.
This is a common meal spread
with the different beef curries
with this type of rice.
(happy music)
Oh, okay, awesome.
- Yeah, certainly, yeah.
- Added in some flour
and still just kind of
working it into little pallets almost.
It really is gonna be like a rice bread.
Obviously, you just like drop it in there?
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
(happy music)
- Then how long will
that need to steam for?
- Five to 10 minutes.
- Okay.
- So when the steam comes
on you have to close it.
- Oh, then you put the lid on, aha!
- And then it'll steam some more.
- And let it steam for about five minutes
and then you'll have a
reinvention of a rice cake bread.
(happy music)
(chattering)
- So the dishes are almost all ready.
The rice cakes are ready.
- 15 minutes.
- Yes, soon, 15 minutes.
Granny says 15 minutes, time for lunch.
(speaking foreign language)
(Happy music)
Setting all the food on the
table, the dishes are ready.
There's like four or five
different all beef meat dishes.
There's an onion sambal.
We're going meat heavy for this meal.
(happy music)
Thank you, it's a
beautiful spread of food.
Everything hand prepared.
- Yeah, hand prepared.
- No recipes.
- No!
- Just she knows it all.
- All natural ingredients.
- Experience!
- Very natural ingredients.
- Thank you.
- No artificial flavor.
- Nothing.
- No artificial anything.
- Yeah.
- Everything natural from here.
- Everything, natural
ingredients on the whole bunch.
- It's a privilege to be here.
Thank you so much for this meal.
- Thank you for being here,
we're happy to have you here.
- Thank you.
and I can't wait to taste the food now.
- [Ruzaina] So this is
our version of the piptu.
Okay, I'm gonna serve the hoof now.
- Hoof?
- Yeah.
Look at all that fat and jelly
and oh my God.
- Oh, that's so good.
- I'm salivating.
(happy music)
This is intestines dried and fat.
(Mark laughing excitedly)
Full on fat.
- You see it jiggling.
- Yeah, look, this.
- Who wants that?
Okay, nice!
- Full on meat feast.
- Full on meat,
love it.
(happy music)
- [Ruzaina] Yeah.
- Ruzaina just dished me an entire plate
filled with all the meat.
Actually there's not even
tongue on the plate yet
and my plate is full.
Juices,
the sauces.
Some of them are actually more juicy,
others are more like a dry curry sauce.
We've got the version of pitu
with the rice and the
flour and then the roti,
and then the sambal,
the trotters, the feet,
the intestines are just...
Although you can see the little shoots.
You can see the meat,
it smells incredible.
You can smell the cardamon, the clove,
the cinnamon in there.
First what you do is you sprinkle,
you douce the pitu in fresh coconut cream.
Oh, yes!
Oh yes!
As much as you need.
And then you can reach in,
you can kinda squish in,
you can mingle it with the meat.
I'm gonna try some of that.
That's just the straight meat cubes.
That beef right there, I
believe it's cooked down with,
you can see the dried chilis in there.
Mm!
- Mm-hmm!
- Oh wow!
Oh, it's so good.
It's so tender, it's so soft.
You taste the dried chilis,
you taste the cardamon
like clove flavor of it.
As you keep on chewing
you taste a little bit
of the sourness in that beef,
which also comes from tamarind.
- Lime and lime juice.
- Mm-hmm!
- Aha!
- Yes!
- One of the meat is
cooked with lime juice.
- Yeah, lime and lime juice.
- Ah!
Oh, and the lime leaves?
- Yes!
- Right, as you showed that one is cooked
with the lime leaves.
Okay, I'll try that one next.
Oh, yeah there's three,
there's three meats.
Right?
- Yes.
- Okay, I'll try this meat next.
This one I think is the
one with the lime leaf.
- [Grandma] The lime leaf.
- You can almost feel how tender it is
just in your finger tips.
(happy music)
Oh yeah!
Mm-hmm!
- Mm-hmm!
(laughing excitedly)
- That one you do taste the lime.
- Yeah.
- Oh, it's like super
balanced of like richness
and citrusiness.
These are some of the food
like you grew up eating?
- Yeah, this is our childhood food.
- Special occasions.
- Family get togethers.
We have this for everything, for anything.
Like anything, for
birthdays, whatever we want.
Like this is--
- It's always this mix.
- When we're together.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- We eat a lot of meat.
- And meat.
- Awesome!
- And also, it's a respect
for the whole cow because
it's an entire animal
being sacrificed.
- Exactly.
- Right?
- So we have to eat everything.
- Every part.
- Not just one part
and throw it out.
- Mm-hmm.
- For us, it's a form of respect
for this animal being
sacrificed, you know.
So we eat all, everything.
- [Mark] Okay, this one is the intestines.
- [Grandma] Try the fat piece.
- Oh, try the fat, okay.
Granny says to try--
- Before it gets cold.
- The chunk of that,
oh, before it gets cold.
Okay, this is the respect right here
just the straight lump of fat.
(happy music)
Oh!
Oh yeah!
That is just like ultra-tender.
- It's nice, yeah?
- It is.
Ultra-tender, just like
jiggly on your tongue.
I'm gonna mix in with some of the sambal
going with intestine, a little shoot.
(happy music)
That's stunning!
And yeah, it's like a totally
different style of rice.
It's very crumbly.
It really worked well to
soak up some of that sauce.
- [Grandma] When you're tired of rice
but you exchange it for a taste.
- Make something like this.
- Yes.
- Okay, I'm moving in for the troder
and I think I'll try that.
Oh yeah!
- That's the hoof.
- The hoof.
- Yeah.
- I'll hop a chunk while
the collagen is just oozing.
(happy music)
Be careful of the little toe bones.
It's not fat but it's jiggly,
it's creamy, it's collageny,
it's so rich and succulent.
I'll have some more once I'm gonna grab
one of those pieces of troder.
Oh!
And that roti is also awesome.
There's coconut stuffed into it.
It's like fluffy, yet hard
and dense at the same time,
all at the same time, and just
wrapped up with that sauce.
What really stands out
is the Sri Lankan version
of all these dishes.
It has like a tropical taste to it,
like the rich and heavy with the meat.
But at the same you taste the lightness
of the lime leaves, the lemongrass.
It's like a combination
of meaty tropicalness.
I'm gonna re-coconut
and kinda work in a bite.
Grab a piece of meat, grab some sambal.
Mm!
Oh!
And then when you a add
a little bit of sambal
it just like compliments everything.
- Because it's like meat, meat, meat, meat
and then little bit of tang.
- Like real fresh.
- Yeah.
(Ruzaina laughs lightly)
- But you still haven't started
the tongue yet. (laughs)
- [Grandma] Oh yeah.
- You forget.
- We gotta try the tongue.
Almost!
- Now the tongue has arrived,
it's waiting now.
- The tongue has arrived.
Okay.
- The tongue is waiting.
- Should we take a time out and tongue it?
(Ruzaina laughing)
About to get up to taste the tongue,
but granny said I gotta finish
all the fat on my plate.
The fat lumps, 'cause it will get cold.
She's like, "Quick, eat all the fats."
I have like six lumps of
fat in my mouth right now.
Okay, granny it's amazing.
Now, let's try the tongue.
- [Ruzaina] It's like a pot roast.
- [Mark] It's like a pot roast but
with extra seasoning and sauce.
- Now, cut it.
- And Ruzaina game me the--
- Pot roast version.
- Oh, it's so tender.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah, this one is more tender
because it cooked longer.
- Look at that.
Oh wow, that is beautiful.
Ruzaina has given me the okay to just take
a bite out of the tongue. (laughs)
(happy music)
Oh wow!
Whoa, that's amazing.
Oh, that's one of the most
satisfying bites I've ever had,
right out of the tongue.
(everyone laughing)
Thank you granny.
- Thank you for Ruzaina grandmother.
- Thank you granny.
- Thank you Ruzaina's grandmother.
- So tender.
This also has like a sourness to it.
Tamarind?
- Yes.
- Like a tamerind sourness.
That is incredible.
It's so tender, like you can
actually cut this with a fork.
- Yeah.
- But dense at the same time.
(chattering)
Yes, thank you.
Okay, and this is the other tongue.
The sambal is incredible.
(cats meowing)
Whoa, a symphony of cats.
(cats meowing loudly)
The hoof is just like melting
into the sauce right now.
(Ruzaina laughs)
- You're doing good now.
I'm very happy that you enjoyed the food.
- Thank you! Thank you!
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Okay, there's
no marrow in this bone
but there's juice and there's fat.
- [Ruzaina] Yeah, juice and fat.
- So you kinda just suck it up.
Oh yeah!
- Very good?
- Kinda like greeny almost.
Greeny, yeah?
- Mm-hmm.
(grandma speaking foreign language)
(Mark sucking bone)
- And it's like cinnamon, even that spice
has seeped in there and just
kinda soaked in the bone.
You can also lick the
jelly off the joints.
Mm! Oh yeah!
As soon as you lick that
your lips get coated
in like a jelly--
(grandma talking)
Like a jelly fat.
- Yeah.
- Oh, it's wonderful!
(everyone laughing)
It's wonderful!
- It's nice, right?
- Really good!
To end the meal that's like
a dessert, meat dessert.
- [Grandma] (laughs) Meat dessert.
(everyone laughing)
- Oh yeah!
- Custard.
- Milk and custard and sugar.
- [Ruzaina] Usually we don't
eat it like that anymore but.
(foreign language)
(happy music)
- [Mark] This is a special custard,
there's nuts in it, eggs.
The traditional way to
eat it is, with a banana,
and what you do is you can
chop it up, or you can eat it
the traditional way, which is
where where you take a bit of
the custard or take an
alternate bite. Or you can..
All together in one bite
with banana and custard.
- A piece of banana
- Look at that.
After the meat feast its
tradition to eat this desert
with the banana to digest the meat.
- [Ruzaina] Its to cool you down.
- [Mark] Yeah its a cool day
in Kandy but I am feeling the
digestions sweats that's
for sure, the meat sweats.
The body is at full digestion
potential right now.
- (laughs)
- Okay, custard..
(eating noises)
- Oh its pretty awesome actually.
Its like a..
oh no I lost a piece of custard in my lap.
That would be my next bite.
Yeah on its own the custard is like,
like simple, its slightly
sweet, its creamy
and you taste the nuts in there.
But when you take the banana with it,
it totally elevates the entire experience
because you've got the creamy tartness of
the banana mingling with the sweetness.
The banana specifically
not overripe so its sour
a little bit.
I think the combination is what makes it.
I'm gonna lean back though.
(happy music)
- Oh wow, what a meal.
- Granny is an amazing cook,
and she cooks everything just
from knowledge from experience and with
ultimate love.
The meat is incredibly
delicious, but the love
you can just taste in every
single bite you take.
Its the late afternoon already
but we're just gonna walk
around Kandy a little bit.
We're gonna do a little bit
of sightseeing, walk around
and maybe eat a little bit more.
(happy music)
(noisy crowd)
We decided to take a walk over
to the Temple of the Sacred
Tooth Relic.
And it dates back too the
late 1500's and its one
of the most sacred Budhist
sites in Kandy and it's
really like the cultural sites
which surrounds the kingdom of Kandy.
And so we're just
gonna.. actually you know
the weather is perfect,
it's cool, it's breezy,
we're just gonna take a little walk around
and mostly see it from the outside.
(happy music)
Something I always love
about Sri Lanka are the trees
and just massive trees
with spanning branches,
the birds the crows,
the trees, they really
stand out, you're gonna
love the trees when
you visit Sri Lanka.
And the palm trees as well are
amazing, the coconut trees.
- Micah is definitely
enjoying himself running
through the crowd.
Micah are you enjoying yourself?
(happy music)
Okay we're off now to walk
around the central downtown
area of Kandy, maybe eat
a little bit and just walk
around and explore it a little bit.
(happy music)
- Uh huh, roti and samba..
(egg cracks)
- [Mark] We've been walking
round Kandy for a little while
just exploring it, it started
drizzling so we stopped
inside. This is kind of like a tea shop,
snack shop, a place to get
quick eats, a place to get
roti, hoppers. We ordered
some roti, we ordered, some
sambal, and we're also gonna
have tea here as well and
hoppers as well.
Try some of the roti, oh
it feels pretty thick.
And then dip it into the sambal.
(busy restaurant noises)
I got a little sambal on my lap.
Its just a tiny bit spicy, quiet salty,
more of like a dried chili flavor though,
but it kind of like,
maybe the lime as well.
Kind of like a sharp saltiness though.
Made from a combination of
rice flower, coconut milk.
The best thing about hoppers
is the method in which
they make the net around
it, skill it, so that
the edges are crispy and the bottom
remains kind of fluffy and gummy.
And its that texture that makes a hopper.
Scoop up some of that sambal.
(busy restaurant noises)
Its good because its so fresh,
the hopper, right out of the
skilla, its warm, its
like gooey on the inside,
crispy on the outside.
But I gotta admit, I'm still
like pretty full from that
lunch feast, the meat feast from granny.
Like that was a significant lunch,
and its still
sitting heavy in my stomach right now.
So its a good thing we're
just snacking right now.
(happy music)
Today has been fantastic, we
drove from Columbo to Kandy,
we arrived to meet with
granny and Ruzaina's aunt,
and Ruzaina.
That was an impressive and
unbelievably delicious meal
and the food was excellent,
the meat was incredible,
the tongue!
But without a doubt, that food
was cooked with so much love
and that's what made it so
spectacular, so incredibly
delicious with every single bite and
that is a meal I will never forget.
I wanna say a massive thank
you to granny, to Anky, to
Ruzaina, for setting
everything up and organizing
everything.
Massive thank you to, you
for watching this video,
please remember to give
it a thumbs up if you
enjoyed it, leave a comment
below I'd love to hear
from you, and If you're
not already subscribed,
click subscribe now and
also click that little bell
icon, so that you get
notified of the next video
I publish.
Thanks again for watching, good
night from Kandy Sri Lanka,
See you on the next video.
And you're gonna wanna keep
on watching this entire
Sri Lanka food and travel
series tomorrow, we're gonna
wake up early, we're
gonna go into the jungle,
for a very unique cultural
indigenous, Sri Lankan food
experience.
So that's coming up stay tuned.
Thanks again for watching,
see you on the next video.